that's Kim Kardashian looking super sexy  alongside Chrissy Teigen in Fergie's new  music video for milf money let's watch  some more because you know it's really  hot while those people were celebrating  the sexy famous moms in the steamy video  some were accusing 35 year old Kim of  Dean photoshopped  Kim wasted no time on Sunday hopping on  snapchat to shut down the haters posting  this behind-the-scenes video and writing  in the caption Co Photoshop hashtag  corset life it's not the first time the  reality star has slammed rumors of  altering her physique Kim took to her  app on Friday to address speculation she  wore butt pads to her sister Khloe's  birthday party on Monday I don't know  where these rumors come from she  candidly explained quote at this point I  think everyone has seen my butt naked  and knows I don't need them lol